cet avion était attendue depuis des mois
monsieur chibani est un tour operator ça
fait 12 ans qu'il travaille avec les
agences de voyages françaises et qu'ils
accueillent les touristes français ici à
l'aéroport datar à 500 km au nord de
nouakchott la capitale de la mauritanie
habituellement la saison touristique
commence dès le mois d'octobre
mais cette année il a fallu attendre la
fin du mois de décembre pour
réceptionner le premier groupe venu de
france donc c'est c'est un peu cet
acteur qui fait qu'il fait kiffer qui
fait qu'elle fait tout le monde chez lui
les touristes français se font rares en
mauritanie
car c'est dans ce pays que tout a
commencé c'est en mauritanie qu'il y a
trois ans a eu lieu le premier attentat
anti français revendiqué par al qaïda au
maghreb islamique aqmi
le 24 décembre 2007 à aleg à 250 km au
sud-est de la capitale
quatre touristes français étaient
exécutés par un commando sur un bord de
route
depuis cet attentat le ministère des
affaires étrangères français réclame à
ses ressortissants la plus grande
vigilance dans certaines régions de
mauritanie le quai d'orsay estime
d'ailleurs qu'une grande partie des
régions du sahara et du sahel sont à
éviter à tout prix
pourtant les touristes qui sont arrivés
aujourd'hui ne semble pas inquiet ce
sont des amateurs de trekking et les
menaces d'al-qaïda leur semble bien
lointaine vous allez faire quoi
marché
dr autre chose
une semaine
et toutes ces histoires d'enlèvement ça
ne vous fait pas peur
à voir
je pense qu'on peut aussi
par des problèmes en france
à sète
la greffe art
je pense qu'amélie midi chez moi
dangereux ici de quatre ans
et je le suis
les biens
bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
est ce la présence discrète de l'armée
française qui rassure ces vacanciers
il semble en tout cas que les militaires
mauritaniens ont tout fait pour
sécuriser la région
sur la route le convoi des touristes
devra s'arrêter à trois postes de
contrôle et nous croiserons quelques
véhicules militaires et des gardes armés
[Musique]
par mesure de sécurité l'agencé de
voyage a également redessiné les
itinéraires de trek le groupe de
touristes marchera six jours dans le
désert mais en ne traversant que les
sites les plus sûres
ces voyageurs sont d'ailleurs loin
d'être des têtes brûlées
ils ont mûrement réfléchie leur décision
avant de partir et dans votre famille
personne ne s'est inquiété parce qu'ils
étaient au courant des enlèvements en
mauritanie de maniement des mères de
famille qui peut pas faire ce que tu
veux que je me sentais tout à fait en
sécurité et moi donc j'ai absolument pas
peur nous avons tenu bon et j'étais
barre sur internet baptisé effectivement
qu'avec ap touristes qui avaient été
enlevés et dont 2 je crois a été tuée et
et que le quai d'orsay proposer aux
français de ne pas partir en mauritanie
mais nous en belgique on n'avait aucune
aucune information travaux reste cette
année vous avez vous n'avez pas hésité
pas du tout je voulais retourner en
mauritanie pour la beauté des paysages
pour l'accueil des mauritaniens pour la
qualité du de l'accueil se retourne
détenus
la beauté du désert je me suis renseigné
et j'ai su que la mauritanie et en
quatre fois plus grande que la france
les événements qui s'y produisent et
c'était loin se produisait très loin et
que le désert était en sécurité avec
tous ces postes militaires avancés donc
voilà je n'étais pas à pleurer
[Musique]
ce groupe de touristes et pourtant peut
être l'un des derniers qui contemplera
les dunes de mauritanie avant longtemps
car samedi dernier deux jeunes français
été tué après avoir été enlevés au niger
dans une zone que l'on croyait aussi
jusqu'ici sans risque nous avons voulu
savoir comment la branche locale
d'al-qaïda réussissait à étendre son
influence peu à peu à l'ensemble des
pays du sahel
et pourquoi les français sont devenus
aujourd'hui leurs cibles privilégiées
[Musique]
nouakchott capitale de la mauritanie
selon les experts un tiers au moins des
membres d'aqmi sont mauritaniens la
prison centrale est l'un des sites les
plus sécurisés de la ville ici sont
incarcérés près d'une centaine
d'islamistes radicaux considérés par les
autorités du pays comme des membres
d'aqmi al qaïda au maghreb islamique
derrière ces murs se trouve en
particulier les auteurs de l'attentât
antifrançais de 2007
nous ne pourrons pas nous arrêter ici
c'est interdit mais nous allons pouvoir
entrer en contact avec l'un des
prisonniers sida remet des journalistes
à nouakchott
il est spécialiste de la question de
l'islam radical en mauritanie
il est l'un des rares à avoir noué des
liens de confiance avec les extrémistes
quand l'important niveau avec son appui
nous allons pouvoir joindre par
téléphone l'un des membres du commando
il s'agit de mohamed ould chabarnou il a
avoué avoir tué les français en 2007
avant de se rétracter lors de son procès
il a été condamné à mort il a
aujourd'hui 30 ans évidemment en
principe chabarnou n'est pas censé
disposer d'un téléphone en prison c'est
la première fois qu'il s'adresse à une
télévision
est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
je m'appelle mohamed oul sidi ould
moustapha ould chabarnou dit abou muslim
je fais partie d'al quaida et cela
m'honore pourquoi pour vous les français
aujourd'hui sont ils devenus des cibles
d'al qaïda
en premier lieu tune in your pas que la
france est complice en afghanistan
contre les musulmans et tu n'ignore pas
non plus qu'elle a plus les pays de la
région les régimes mécréants qui
gouvernent par des lois contraires aux
lois d'allah en terre d'islam contre
l'islam est contre les musulmans mais
les citoyens français qui sont la cible
d'al qaïda est ce que vous les
considérez comme innocent en vérité ils
sont innocents
mais le gouvernement français lui n'est
pas innocent c'est lui le criminel
écouter des gardes sont entrés je vous
rappelle à partir d'un autre téléphone
d'accord après ce premier échange et un
discours attendu
mohamed chabarnou va nous rappeler et se
faire plus précis plus menaçant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non allô c'est abou slim
[Applaudissements]
nous allons lui demander à nouveau
pourquoi s'en prendre aujourd'hui à des
touristes français bien sûr que c'est
légitime
allah le tout-puissant dit celui qui
vous agressent agressé le comme ils vous
agresse ces gens-là nous agressent et
nous aussi nous les agréent sont je le
dis clairement le touriste en mauritanie
ou dans n'importe quelle partie du
sahara
il est permis de l'enlever et de le tuer
pourquoi la france est elle devenue une
ennemie aux yeux de mohamed chabarnou
d'où lui vient cette rhétorique et ses
arguments ou les at il appris nous
sommes à une heure de route du centre de
nouakchott la capitale de la mauritanie
oumou elle courra est une madrassa une
école coranique que chabarnou à
fréquenter cette école réputée a été
fondé il ya quatre siècles des étudiants
viennent ici apprendre le coran des
quatre coins du monde
[Musique]
nous arrivons à l'heure de la prière
l'école voit passer des centaines
d'élèves chaque année mohamed chabarnou
n'a fait ici qu un bref séjour et cette
école coranique est connu pour ses
positions modérées mais comme le
reconnaît l'ouléma qui enseigne ici il
n'est pas impossible de croiser des
étudiants aux positions extrémistes des
recruteurs au service d'aqmi je ne
conteste pas cela il ya des jeunes qui
viennent d'algérie il étudie juste la
langue arabe en est la preuve que ce
sont des extrémistes c'est qu'il n'ait
tu dis jamais la théologie il ne prit
même pas avec nous dans les mosquées il
pris seul il étudie uniquement en langue
arabe
jamais la théologie et quand vous les
identifier
nous les expulsions nous leur demandant
de partir nous on ne veut pas subir de
mal de l'enfer
nous leur disons toi tu es indésirables
et si on ne dénonce pas à la police mais
il faut quitter notre école si mohamed
chabarnou et les autres membres du
commando était ici devant vous qu'est ce
que vous leur diriez je leur dirai de se
repentir de revenir vers allah et de
prendre la bonne voie la voie du
prophète et de ses compagnons les
compagnons du prophète ne trahissent
jamais s'ils veulent faire le djihad
qu'il étudie d'abord ils n'ont jamais
étudié le djihad légal qui l'étudient
qu'ils respectent les règles du jihad
s'il avait étudié les règles il n'aurait
jamais fait ce qu'ils ont fait ils
n'auraient jamais agressé un étranger ni
un musulman sous la protection des lois
musulmanes
mohamed ould chabarnou at-il fait de
mauvaise rencontre à l'école coranique
pour en savoir plus le lendemain nous
sommes allés trouver l'un de ses amis
d'enfance
[Musique]
un bout-à-bout est le seul qui est
accepté de parler du ralliement de
chabarnou à al qaïda et des réseaux qui
pourrait expliquer son geste
ceal jeunes qui se retrouvent et
franchement je vous dis direct passage
août et s'est retrouvé en bobines et
indécise à wall e reçoit moelleux
heureusement je dis malheureusement
personne n'a été arrêtée là pour eux
pour l'extirper dit aimer de ces gens là
ils s'étaient de petits voyages de temps
en temps mais après des voyages
probablement du côté du mali en fait
mais ça s'est passé avec d'autres
moments il a changé de tenue
vestimentaire quoi
avant profiter dit pas qui portait des
jeans porter de la marque et il a
abandonné tout ça
mais bon à mon niveau est habillé
comment porter
j'étais là bas
je conçois général
regardez regarder des chaînes il ya des
chaînes satellitaires
j'ai jasé la laiterie comptable qui
passe d information d information qui
demande à ce qu'on me problème
comment
le problème israélo-palestinien
par exemple
il était sensible à ces choses là ici
qui diffuse la série bousquet le message
ça je
l'occident c'est quoi voilà
les problèmes de tous les problèmes du
monde c'est l'occident
[Musique]
l'occident désigner comme ennemi c'est
un message que les fidèles peuvent
entendre et si dans certaines mosquées
dans certains quartiers dans les ruelles
de nouakchott la misère est un terreau
fertile pour l'islam radical
25 jeunes de ce quartier auraient
rejoint les rangs d'al qaïda et serait
mort au combat en mauritanie et en
algérie en 2009 un évangéliste américain
a été abattu ici en pleine rue en plein
jour mohamed ould chabarnou lui semble
avoir été endoctrinés lors d'un voyage
au mali c'est là-bas qu'aqmi a implanté
ces bases nous décidons de passer la
frontière
[Musique]
il faut plusieurs heures de route pour
rallier le mali puis pour monter vers le
nord vers la région dont les brigades
d'aqmi ont fait leur zone d'influencé
le contraste avec ce que nous avons vu
en mauritanie est saisissant ici pas de
poste de contrôle pas de patrouille de
gendarmerie
la dernière ville traverse et gao est
déjà à 300 kilomètres derrière autour de
nous le désert à perte de vue
cette région a toujours été une région
instable une zone de trafic mais
aujourd'hui elle est plus dangereuse que
jamais dans le 4 4 nous sommes
accompagnés par des touareg
ils garantissent notre sécurité sur
leurs conseils pour être le plus discret
possible
nous nous sommes habillés selon la
coutume locale
on quitte la piste
pourquoi tu ne contrôles pas c'est
le poste constate anne vallaeys il est
où le post montre le mois
axa
à ses larmes elle
nous contournons le poste de contrôle
les gendarmes maliens pourrait nous
refoulé ou pire selon certains de nos
informateurs la corruption et l dans
cette zone qu'il pourrait signaler notre
présence à des preneurs d'otages nous
passons au large les gendarmes
n'interviendront pas
ils sont pas équipés j'ai dit
il ya lieu
ils sont là pour le foot est un gars qui
passe d' à bout de la maladie
par sa maison pas là pour traquer les
trafiquants en tête
de vastes contrées
mais autre côté ici
il ya aucune autorité
au bout de la piste dans quelques heures
nous atteindrons kidal la dernière ville
du nord du mali
nous sommes maintenant au coeur de la
zone contrôlée par l'aqmi
les combattants d'al qaïda
[Musique]
il ne serait pas prudent de sortir dans
les rues de kidal avec une caméra
mais il ya tout de même une solution
pour avoir un aperçu de la ville monté
sur le toit
kidal et la cité ancestrale des touareg
cette minorité ethnique a toujours été
en mauvais termes avec le gouvernement
central
[Musique]
notre guide et un touareg il connaît la
situation il nous a confirmé qu'une
frange de la population touarègue a
appris à vivre avec les zones de l'aqmi
établi dans la région
certains ont même rejoint leurs rangs
si on dit que les élections allaient
bien vrai qu'on peut raconter ce qu'ils
sont à redon mais je trouve qu'ils ont
des raisons de les faire par exemple
on vient nous dire combien de nos
populations qui sont dans leurs
troupeaux avant d'appliquer bon ça si la
religion musulmane c'est votre religion
on est là pour combattre les clés le
coup farikou faire les infidèles les
américains et pour défendre mais
musulmans qui sont opprimés ailleurs
dans le monde par exemple l'irak
l'afghanistan le falastin la seconde
raison c'est quoi ce but et ça c'est
important scénariste une raison
financière et économique du moins est-ce
parce que si c'est le seul à tenir le 6
d'employés
la troisième raison c'est parce que tu
sais toi qui sont là sont toujours en
vie dessous de deux ans j'ai en quelque
sorte de démo ou d une marginalisation
qu'ils ont subis et qu'il subit jusqu'à
présent
[Musique]
pour des questions de sécurité nous ne
resterons pas plus de quelques heures à
kidal mais sur le chemin du retour nous
demandons à nos contacts de nous amener
à la rencontre des touareg
sur la piste nous allons croiser un
modeste campement de nomades dans le
désert il y a des centaines de tentes
comme celle là et nous allons le
constater à l'image de ces trois famille
de bergers
la majorité des touareg vie dans un
grand dénuement des proies faciles
recruter parfois parler commando
islamiste comme main d'oeuvre ou comme
simple relais d'information l'évocation
de l'aqmi ci provoque méfiance et peur
le connaissent pas dit que les halles
entendez parler d in il ignore tout des
cons et laisse tranquille qu'on vit
comme des siècles y alliez chez notre
tranquillité comme d'habitude nous
reprenons la route
mais avant de rentrer en france il nous
reste une dernière rencontre grâce à nos
contacts nous sommes entrés en liaison
avec un homme qui se présente comme
membre actif de l'aqmi son nom de guerre
et abou moussab il a accepté d'être
interviewé nous indiquerons ni le lieu
ni la date exacte de cet entretien les
propos que nous avons recueillies
correspondent à la propagande connu d'al
qaïda la france est désormais une cible
et vous allez l'entendre ces extrémistes
n'ignore rien de l'actualité des débats
qui agitent notre pays
vous habitez en france et vous savez ce
qui se passe là-bas pour les musulmans
vous savez ce qui se passe pour les
mosquées des musulmans tous les jours
dans les médias il y à des attaques de
certains chrétiens contre les mosquées
contre les femmes musulmanes contre les
hommes musulmans
il ya là bas le racisme anti musulman
il y à une femme politique française qui
a dit dans un récent discours que la
prière dans la rue en france est une
sorte de colonisation et le gouvernement
français a interdit le niqab et tout ça
c'est du racisme contre les musulmans
on ne voit jamais le gouvernement
français parler des juifs des chrétiens
des hindous
il ne parle que de l'islam de la lutte
contre l'islam et c'est ça la politique
choisie par sa cause et vis-à-vis des
musulmans depuis qu'il règne sur la
france
l'homme va poursuivre par une menace une
menace directe contre la france contre
les dirigeants français et contre les
intérêts français dans le nord de
l'afrique
nous avons choisi de ne pas le laisser
proféré ces menaces nous nous voulons de
la france une chose très claire nous
voulons qu'elles laissent les musulmans
tranquille et qu'elle arrête de suivre
les états unis et qu'elle retire ses
forces des pays musulmans
à partir de là elle sera en sécurité de
la part des moudjahiddine c'est ce que
nous voulons de la france ces menaces ne
sont pas nouvelles elles ont déjà été
proférées par oussama ben laden
en octobre 2010 mais elle résonne
aujourd'hui différemment car cet
entretien nous l'avons enregistré
quelques jours seulement avant la prise
d'otage de niamey qui a coûté la vie à
deux jeunes français
comment s'appellent ces montagnes
c'est moins 20 dh que tu as fait
le battre
au moment de quitter définitivement le
sahara nous faisons un dernier regard
sur les massifs montagneux du nord
il est clair qu'aujourd'hui aucun des
pays de la région n'est en mesure de
déloger seul l'aqmi de ce qui est devenu
son sanctuaire quelque part dans ces
montagnes sept otages dont cinq français
sont retenus depuis maintenant presque
quatre mois
[Musique]